foreign
publication emerged
that reported an experimental finding in
which if I understood it correctly
the S protein that is the spike protein
Gene from
the Omicron variant
was somehow
grafted into a wild type which I think
means the original Stars cov2 genome
right the Wuhan string wild type sarsko
V2 it was pretty wild wild side I really
we're going to use that term here I hope
I'm not inventing that part but I do
believe they used wild type WT but
anyway the point is
they did this fascinating slash
terrifying experiment in which they took
this Escape variant
produced Gene for Spike protein and they
put it on the Wuhan strain I think it
was the Wuhan strain
and
then they did some stuff with it where
they gave it to a bunch of mice and 80
of them died okay now okay
virus that they had created uh Frank and
Franken virus
the Franken squared virus yeah
considering
it maybe at this point it's hard it's
hard to keep track of the exponents
actually in light of the weirdness
surrounding the Genome of Omicron maybe
it is cubed but anyway we digress the
point is one
that suggests something very frightening
I mean a it could be it's possible that
the mice are weirdly vulnerable and that
that is not in any way indicative of
what would happen in people if such a
thing occurred hi
um
it's like you don't have a computer let
me sit on your lap
um but
let's just say
one
the idea that this new set of genes for
the spike protein which now exists in
the world freely floating around
infecting people
that that combined with
the background from a strain that is
presumably no longer floating around but
certainly could be yeah right it's not
like we did something clever that got
rid of it it just other things out
competed it in the in the Swarm right
there's nothing in what you read that
suggested how difficult this would be to
have happened naturally I think the
point is as an evolutionary biologist I
feel
perfectly well positioned to say
probably not it's not like it's it's
like a person being born with an
elephant trunk or something no I don't
think so I think it's the opposite I
think I think the point is
um a we don't know a ton about how all
this works but a person being infected
with two strains simultaneously could
there be different oh I see too soon
right so I guess I'm not expecting to
see this leap in one go but the the idea
that the whole quadrant the design space
involves a simple taking of two things
that were produced by whatever process
got us here and putting them in the same
virus produces that kind of mortality
rate that's terrifying what is also
terrifying is that somehow in 2022
people are still running experiments oh
my God yep right I mean for one thing
at the very least
these people just handed a tremendously
potentially dangerous formula to
whatever hates us
right
you need a certain amount of biological
knowledge to do what they did but
no but rocket science now a plausible
end product bioweapon is known
yep which takes considerable
technological know-how and money to
build the lab in which to implement that
know-how but but still it exists now
let's just say
I'm not a molecular biologist I'm not a
laboratory scientist hopefully I've
misunderstood something about what I've
read but and I haven't seen I don't need
any paper you're talking yeah
um but
the whole thing read as extremely uh
alarming both from the point of view of
what it suggests could evolve
naturally naturally at this point
or what somebody could arrange and the
fact that people are now still playing
these kinds of games in Labs even though
we've seen how you know again a function
experiment that
turned a virus into something with a
comparatively low case fatality rate
still turned the world on its head yeah
right the destruction from this thing is
astronomical and you know will in the
end be indefinitely large given that we
now have no way to control it
[Music]